hold your kids my daughter is 10 and my
son just turned 7 on Tuesday ok I'm
curious about this because my kids are
similar ages where are they on the
holidays what do they believe in what do
they not believe in - they have a savvy
- the holidays because my daughter is my
daughter is
I was hoping she's 10 last year was our
our first year but she didn't believe in
Santa and I was hoping we'd have a
couple more years but her friend told
her and then once it's out there it's
out there and somebody told me that
somebody told me a very smart man said
once they realize it'll probably be
Santa the whole wall comes down and it's
exactly what happened it you know I like
them to like believe as much as possible
for a while yes I think it's fun for
kids to believe it gets sad if they get
to be too old yeah I know and they're
like I have a my brother's like 54 and
he's like Santa's coming
don't worry Neal we'll talk about it
yeah just had this happen my my
ten-year-old daughter and I'm like two
months ago confronted my wife and said
and she said it with a straight face she
said because my daughter lost a tooth
and she said mom are you the tooth fairy
and my wife said she looked her in the
face and just felt like I can't lie to
her she's old and she said yes I'm the
tooth fairy
my daughter lost it tears just crying
crying it's like I would a lie why would
a lie well that's a stone wall I'm like
a guy in the mob I just no no not me but
then she said well Santa's real olicity
and my leg went yeah yeah Santa
[Applause]
but work I come home from work like a
half hour later and I said mommy told
you and told me what happened with the
tooth fairy and then she said daddy are
you Santa and it was the same thing I
looked her in it I could not lie to her
and I feel like I'm sorry honey yeah i'm
sanna and she loses it again and she
says why would you lie to me I didn't
have an answer I was a magic any kid
that believes in the Easter Bunny has
got to pee that's crazy crazy
what could you like a jar you buddies
coming that gets me mad my kids are very
into Saint Patrick's Day and they do
this whole leprechaun trap and I it is
strategic
it is thought-out I'm gonna make it
comfortable so that the leprechaun will
want to come in yeah and then I'm
crackin there's a big thing come down
and break its neck would if they thought
a bad bed and so when my daughter asked
me she said Santa then she said tooth
fairy
Easter Bunny she said leprechauns and I
said those are real yeah you got to hold
the line unless my husband - my husband
I can't get him - you know like if you
ask him about God he will laughs laughs
laughs but leprechauns he is going to
convince our daughter